Bitcoin versus gold which one is better
obviously Bitcoin because gold can be
confiscated since the dawn of time Kings
and governments have just been
confiscating people's gold whether it's
Roosevelt whether it's the Nazis with
Bitcoin nobody needs to even know that
you own it due to the very high level of
anonymity that it enabled with gold of
course you can leave it under your
mattress or in your house but that can
be ceased and confiscated usually people
tend to leave their gold in a vault
which you have to give your customer
name and so again it can be seized if
you say the wrong thing on social media
or if you're Pro tesing bodily autonomy
like they tried to do in Canada well
then they can just come take your gold
you cannot take somebody's Bitcoin